Photoshop is one of the most powerful
tools in any entrepreneurs tool belt and
today I'm going to show you how to
isolate your subject and remove any
background as easy as one two three
what's going on guys my name is David
Tomic welcome back to the channel
today we're talking all about Photoshop
so like always let's get straight into
it and dive right into the program so
the photo I've selected today is the
photo taken back in 2016 for the regroup
collection of the wire watchers product
launch it was taken inside a lightbox
which makes it very simple to take out
the background power but it doesn't
matter if you're taking the photo from a
lightbox
or outside in the everyday situation the
principles are taking out the
backgrounds are exactly the same if you
want to follow along with this tutorial
I've linked the photo down below for you
to download otherwise open your desired
photo in Photoshop and let's get started
with Photoshop open there's only a
couple of things that you're gonna need
to use and that's one the polygonal
lasso tool and to accomplish or cutting
the teacher along the way if you don't
have the polygonal lasso tool
highlighted already you can simply hold
and press the third icon until three
objects appear and select the cleaner
lasso tool alternatively you can press
shift and L and tap through the
different glass--oh tools now we're
going to want to zoom in as close to
this photo as possible to make sure we
get an accurate outline of the product
the simplest way is to hold ctrl and
press + alternatively you can hold alt
and scroll with your scroll wheel if you
have a master the scroll wheel to get
started if you want to simply click on
your first point and slowly outline the
entire photo if you make any mistakes a
job writing like this you can simply
press the backspace and we'll remove
that last node another trick that you're
going to need to know is when you get to
a little bit higher up in this photo and
you can't see any more of the photo you
all you need to do is let the mouse
scroll to the edges and it's going to
move the photo further
now outlining this is gonna take a
little bit of time so I'm going to
possible this video here
over the whole object now outline do you
want to take out these little spaces in
between the watch to make sure it's a
clean product photo again we're going to
hold it up and scroll in now there's one
thing that you need to take note of and
it's these four little icons at the top
the first one represents a single
outline at where a single selection only
it means once you make a second
selection the original one will be
removed the second icon here lets you do
multiple selections the third takes out
of an original selection and fourth
divides the selection into a unique
space
now if the purposes of this video we're
going to be the third tool we're going
to need to remove these little sections
from the already outlined image if you
do need to make a straight line you can
hold the shift key which is going to
lock this selection tool in any
direction that you need to
if you do make a mistake and want to
start again you can simply press the
Escape key and deselect everything that
you've already started to do okay so
once you outline an entire watch and all
the little spaces in between it's as
simple as pressing ctrl shift I to
invert the selection and pressing the
Delete key to delete the background now
if you also want to add a white
background or a black background or
potentially place it into another photo
all you're going to need to do is create
a new layer which is down here in the
bottom taking one from the bin click
that one drag the layer underneath the
watch itself
head over to the Paint Bucket press and
hold until you get paint bucket tool and
then select your colors you can either
have black or if the usually longwood
year you can also add white now if using
shot flag one thing that you need to
know is that shop phone likes to have a
1 by 1 grid for its photos so the best
way to achieve a 1 by 1 square is to
press the C button to crop go up here
and go one by one Square and click OK
and that's all there is to it guys
Photoshop is a very simple program once
you understand the basics hopefully with
this information you're gonna go back
and be able to take out the background
of any photo for any product on your
website and become a great entrepreneur
in 2019 black always I'm gonna be
releasing a new econ video every Monday
from here on in so smashing that
subscribe button
20:19 style and I'll see you in the next
one